Це село Панчеве на Кіровоградщині.
Саме тут знайшли прихисток понад три сотні переселенців переважно зі сходу України.
Для них дві подруги - Віта і Тетяна - облаштували понад 50 покинутих хат.
Почали зі звичайного волонтерства, а коли стали приїжджати переселенці - зрозуміли, що треба їх десь поселяти.
Тож знаходили власників порожніх будинків і з їхньої згоди наводили там порядки.
У першу чергу, ми хотіли наближати нашу перемогу.
Якщо наші хлопці захищають нас там, то ми повинні захищати тут.
І ці люди, які до нас приїхали, залишилися без нічого: вони залишилися без будинків, деякі втратили своїх рідних.
Як їм не допомогти?
Щоб ви розуміли, були такі будинки, що ми заходили, а там дірки були від щурів, щурі поточили стіни.
Ми колотили шпаклівки, зашпакльовували стіни, ці діри, вкладали туди отруту.
Потім фіранки, все повністю. Білували. Де треба було білувати - білували, фарбувати - фарбували, клеїли шпалери.
У цих будинках взагалі нічого не було: ні меблів, ні одіял, ні подушок, взагалі нічого.
Просто порожні стіни стояли. Деякі будинки і по 20 років ніхто не жив. Вони просто були в жахливому стані.
В один із таких будинків заселилася сім'я із Торецька Донецької області.
Їхнє місто знаходиться поблизу лінії фронту і постійно обстрілюється ворожою артилерією, тому залишатися там було неможливо.
Я думаю, ви бачили, що у Торецьку відбувається. Садок доньки розбили.
Спочатку школу, потім садок. Загалом майже нічого вже в місті не залишилося.
Чоловік на шахті там також працював. Там уже й шахт нема. Я навіть не знаю, до чого там повертатися.
Яка робота буде, яке що?
У Панчеве вони приїхали в серпні. Заселилися у старий закинутий будинок і тепер пристосовуються до нового життя.
У своєму домі, каже жінка, мали все: опалення, воду, туалет із ванною, ремонт.
А тут доводиться щодня набирати воду з колодязя, рубати дрова, митися у мисці і сушити одяг на вулиці.
Глибоко дуже вода, 30 метрів глибина колодязя.
І він порожній до самого низу.
Це нам ще допомогли, його почистили, бо вода була жовта, вся брудна, він застійний у них, ніхто не жив.
Нам його почистили, але знову ж таки, вода все одно жовта.
Ми на приготування, на пиття купуємо воду магазинну. Ну, а це для прання.
І ставимо на грубку грітися.
Так одне, друге відро, так гріємо, перемо, миємо, якось так.
Дрова сушимо, заносимо, щоб можна було грубку розтопити.
Та головне - є дах над головою і діти в безпеці, каже Тетяна.
У цій старій хаті не було зовсім нічого - лише голі стіни.
Все інше привезли волонтери: килими, ліжка, шафи, штори, одіяла, подушки, телевізори та комп'ютери.
Тільки стіни пооббивали, бо стіни мокрі, з вулиці все, цвіль…
ну, ви бачите, що там відбувається. Оббили хоча б, щоб діти не торкалися цих стін.
Проводку чоловік доробляв, таке, елементарне, розетки, вмикачі.
Вікна забивав клейонкою, бо дме з вікон.
Спочатку волонтерки заселяли людей у кращі будинки.
Дуже закинуті оминали, бо привести їх більш-менш до пуття було вкрай затратно.
Однак слава про гостинне село розходилася між людьми, і переселенців ставало все більше.
Тому почали селити навіть у дуже занедбані будинки: з обідраними стінами, без побілки, шпаклівки і шпалер.
Утім, навіть такі умови не злякали сім'ю із Краматорська.
Подружжя вирішило самостійно робити ремонт, а волонтерки привезли все, що для цього потрібно.
Оце така кімната була до ремонту.
А потім оце наробили ремонтів. Це одна була житлова, ми сюди заїхали більш-менш, а потім вже порядки наводили.
Були якісь старі речі старих хазяїв, пляшки, банки.
Шпалер не було, у тій кімнаті тільки поклеєні шпалери були.
Це ми заїхали в ту кімнату, в крайню, і там жили, а тут трошки наводили порядок, стелі побілили, шпалери поклеїли.
Тепер їхній будинок - не впізнати. На вулиці чоловік із жінкою повирубували чагарі і збудували туалет.
Там, де немає скла на вікнах, позабивали плівкою. А всередині будинку створили мінімальний затишок, хоч і зі старими меблями.
Чоловік зробив сам з піддонів, збив стіл для дитини. І там також на кухні полички якісь, під взуття поличка, все самі робили з піддонів.
Це ми тут спимо, це у нас тут їдальня, ми тут їмо.
Це у нас тут груба, це ж пічка топиться, гріється, тут тепло. Це наша кімната.
А дітки в нас там, в сусідній кімнаті. Дівчата вчать уроки.
А Володимир, переселенець із Дружківки Донецької області, встиг не лише навести порядок у будинку, а навіть засадити город у селі і зробити закрутки.
Земля тут гарна, краща, ніж наша. У нас степи, земля суха, а тут земля дихає.
Пекінську капусту виростив, виростив дайкон, виростив картоплю, помідори.
Навіть вийшло ще трохи продати і на армію пожертвувати.
У себе вдома він також вирощував овочі і викладав в технікумі.
Після перемоги планує повернутися додому, але каже, що Панчеве і місцеві жителі назавжди залишаться для нього рідними.
Друга батьківщина. Якщо, дай Бог, все буде нормально, приїжджайте до мене, як додому.
Переселенці у селі знаходять не лише прихисток, а й роботу. Більшість із них - гірники.
А тут працюють у полі, на будівництві і у фермерських господарствах.
Займаємося різною роботою: то ремонтами машин, трішки будівництвом, це влітку.
І там допомагаємо також на прихистку. То там, то там, всього по трошки.
Працюю я тут зварювальником. Сіялки, борти, причепи варю.
Ми три машини зробили для ЗСУ, екскаватор зробили для ЗСУ. Робота є.
Село від цього також у виграші. Зараз у Панчевому проживає півтори тисячі місцевих і 178 переселенців.
Багато з них можуть залишитися тут назавжди, бо не мають, куди повертатися.
Більше молоді не дасть селу зістаритися і вимерти, а нові робочі руки дозволять краще розвиватися, переконаний староста села.
Багато повлаштовувалися і в агрофірмі, і у фермерів, і добре працюють, і стараються.
Вже кілька людей кажуть, що ми, може, у вас і залишимося.
Для села більше населення, більше діток у школі, в дитячому садку.
Можливо, буде більше робочих місць.
Все залежить від наших підприємців, у нас шість фермерів і велика агрофірма.
Можливо, якесь тваринництво буде. Хотілося б, щоб наше село розквітало.
Жінки-переселенки також без роботи не сидять, постійно допомагають у фонді.
Ганна приїхала з Рубіжного Луганської області. Від її квартири нічого не залишилося.
У себе в місті вона працювала заступницею директора гімназії.
А тепер поєднує одразу дві роботи - шкільну і волонтерську.
Ми приходимо сюди щодня, у кого який час є. Взагалі-то у нас графік з 12 до 17, але в мене уроки,
в мене звіти, свої робочі справи. Як тільки я їх завершую, я приходжу сюди і допомагаю, чим можу.
Наразі працюю з документами. Це те, що я вмію робити.
Алла змушена переселятися вже вдруге. У 2014 році вона із сім'єю виїхала з окупованого Донецька
і багато років працювала у "Червоному Хресті" у Дружківці.
Я волонтер "Червоного Хреста", у мене є навички всього цього, ми пройшли там.
Усім допомагали нашим переселенцям до сьогодні, поки ми не приїхали сюди.
Тут Тані сказала також: виручайте, тому що я не зможу сидіти вдома без роботи,
без нічого, без моїх людей, без моїх оцих дітей, без цього всього.
Треба працювати, рухатися, жити далі.
Тетяна і Віта зареєстрували благодійну організацію і тепер розподіляють гуманітарну допомогу для переселенців із кількох навколишніх сіл.
А ще плекають плани на майбутнє: хочуть побувати для переселенців лазню і пральню, щоб можна було помитися і випрати одяг.
А також облаштувати для них безкоштовний гуртожиток з усіма умовами
- опаленням, водою, електрикою та новим ремонтом.
Розмови про це вже ведуть із районною радою.
Ми з ними все робимо. Вони завжди готові нам допомогти, а ми - їм.
Тому що ми - одна родина з ними. Ці люди увійшли в наші сім'ї.
Ми разом, ми об’єдналися і всі разом. Якщо вся Україна буде об'єднуватися - наша перемога настане дуже швидко.